it's a special weekend the rock and roll
marathon is back and race weekend fun
and experiences start today lasting into
sunday bianca holman is live with what
runners can expect this year it's just a
good thing that it's back in person
bianca
yeah sure has been too long it all
starts today the first event is actually
going to be the health and wellness expo
that's happening here at resorts world
the newest property here on the strip
and so this kicks off race weekend it's
been about 800 days since this series
was in las vegas yeah we're talking fall
2019. for the first time in history of
the race
the saturday 5k will take place under
the neon lights of the fremont street
experience and there's also the 10k
course and this year was definitely all
about new experiences
it was so difficult to be away from
events and so the only kind of silver
lining is that we were able to take that
time and really
dive into
how we could reimagine this event when
we could come back and so we've really
reimagined the entire experience from
top to bottom
so thousands of runners will see these
big changes with these new experiences
how they will even load the start line
all the details people are going to
notice all the different changes so
coming up in the next sapphire we're
going to share more about what runners
can expect and also an overview of
traffic for us local so you'll
definitely want to tune in for that
nate of course we'll be diving more into
it tomorrow morning but just want to
give you a heads up as you start making
plans for your weekend bianca holman
live local now